did you ever hear from uh Candace
CCV yeah
um
yeah after our
so
it's it's tough it's tough so Candace
and I
I've had to accept that we're never I'm
never gonna change her mind about what
about her acceptance and beliefs with
the lgbtq community
um and it's tough because I when I
called her out on the internet I didn't
mean for it to be as explosive as
explosive as it was and I think that was
a moment for me of like all right this
was a mess up you know what I mean and
so she called and we talked well the
first thing was not was just about you
said she was mean to you yes yes so that
that we called about
um she called me she was like will you
make a statement online and I was like I
I said no I said but if you say
something and you say whatever I was
like all replying all engage and I'll
make it very clear that like
there's no fire you know what I mean and
so we did that and everything was fine
and
whatever and then a few months later
some stuff came out about her
saying that lgbtq relationships were not
traditional marriage and she wants to
make movies that are specifically about
to change networks because of that yeah
and it wasn't so much that she didn't
want to do movies about that she didn't
want to work for a network that did
exactly and so it was a little bit like
oh you got me to say this and then now
you're doing that you know what I mean
and so with that I I think I posted
something about that or maybe I made it
and saved it in my drafts no I think I
posted it
I don't know I don't remember I don't
know I don't I don't either
um I either posted it or I was going to
look it up if you posted it where would
it be it either be on my Tick Tock or my
Instagram
um so see if there's something on her
Tick Tock that mentions but it felt like
a knife right because you already like
squashed beef and then it's like darn
and then it was like I have beef with
you again for something yeah and it was
like a lot bigger I just wanted that
wasn't a personal well it is personal
but I'm just saying it's bigger than
personal to my family you know what I
mean and and I just was like you know
what
nah you know I just had to like step
back and when we're never gonna agree
there's some really sad things behind
closed doors that I've just had to be
like okay the world doesn't need to know
these things I don't need to publish
these things I don't need to talk about
these things but I need the world to
know that I do not stand with her and I
don't agree
with her
um because I gotta stand up for my
people
I think we all have to stand up for all
people that I agree that's that's the
key we have to stand up for all people
and everybody is Love Is Love yep and
everybody needs respect and if you're
publicly showing disrespect and I think
she could be a really good example of
religion doesn't mean homophobia
you know what I mean and I think that's
a very common misconception is that you
can't have both religion and acceptance
for lgbtq Community yeah you can and you
can you can and I think she could be a
fine example of that because she is very
open about her religion and very public
about it
um but she chooses not to be and that's
that's okay you know that's not her life
path
but being friends with her isn't mine
foreign
[Music]